the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group tonight on
politics now keeping a roof over
nevadan's heads
the program meant to help renters and
landlords as the eviction moratorium is
lifted plus
i'm multi-layered i also know how to
kick off the heels
throw on some boots and get some stuff
done republican senate candidate
shirelle mendenhall talks to us about
her campaign
i would love to see policies that bring
back manufacturing to
the u.s and congressional candidate
carolina serrano
answers questions about immigration
policy and working
on the trump campaign
from eight news now this is politics now
keeping people off the streets and money
in landlords pockets is the goal of the
legislature as the eviction moratorium
is lifted
thanks for joining us i'm vanessa murphy
john is off tonight
the eviction moratorium lifts in less
than an hour
governor sisilak and other leaders are
promoting the rental assistance program
created by assembly bill 486
it prevents tenants from being evicted
if they have proof they filed a rental
assistance
application the court places a hold on
the case
and arrangements are made for the
landlord until the application goes
through
landlords who own single-family homes
can also apply for assistance through
the program
as the pandemic has changed and evolved
so has our approach to the moratorium
and we've been able to build out rental
assistance programs
with state and county partners mediation
programs with the court system
and most recently by partnering with the
nevada legislature
to create a so-called glide path for
evictions
it's important to note in order to
qualify for this you have to apply for
rental assistance so
leaders recommended applying now the
county is processing
eight hundred to one thousand
applications a week
there are currently eight thousand
waiting to be processed
the county said it has paid out 165
million in rental and utility help
to about ninety thousand programs in the
last year
we have more info on the program at
eightnewsnow.com
a congressional committee is looking
into companies that evicted tenants
during the moratorium
including one here in southern nevada
south carolina democratic congressman
james clyburn
points to court records which reveal
that some large
corporate landlords have evicted many
tenants
during the covid19 pandemic congressman
clyburn says
the las vegas-based group siegel group
filed around
570 eviction orders during the
moratorium
that's despite receiving millions of
dollars in federal
rental assistance money congress has
taken action to ensure
that reynolds experience and hardship
can receive financial help
to stay in their homes of course the
ultimate recipient
of these funds or the landlords
to whom rent is paid the federal
moratorium runs out this weekend
siegel group will still have to provide
more information
on how many evictions they followed
through with to the committee
if you are in danger of being evicted
there are resources
we have information again at
eightnewsnow.com
well the masks are back in las vegas
everyone now has to wear a mask
indoors whether they are vaccinated or
not the state is following the cdc's
latest recommendations
which applies to counties with at least
50 cases per
100 000 people right now clark county's
rate is about
four and a half times that we're one of
12 counties in the state
where the new mask mandate applies
clark county is considering paying
people 100
each to get vaccinated that will not
include people who have already gotten
the vaccine
commissioner tick sega bloom says the
county could budget 10 million dollars
from the hundreds of millions it
received
in federal coronavirus relief that would
cover
100 for one hundred thousand people in
clark county getting the vaccine
commissioner sega bloom says more and
more private companies are requiring
vaccines or
proof of a negative test the reality is
employers are gonna start saying
we want you to either be vaccinated or
get tested on your own dime
every week or twice a week so i mean
there are going to be some financial
penalties involved whereas if we give
you this
100 then you make money as opposed to
have to pay money
the commission will talk about this at
tuesday's meeting
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
has gathered a big war chest for next
year's senate race
the democrat has raised about 11 million
dollars so far this year
two republicans have filed to run
against her reno wounded warrior veteran
sam brown
and sherelle mendenhall she's a former
miss nevada 2020 and miss california and
runs a talent agency
i talked with mendenhall to ask about
the senate race and where she stands on
issues
what's your stance on immigration and do
you support building a wall
um i believe that there is a great
process for people to come into this
country and that needs to be adhered too
i do believe we need to build the wall
we're at you know the last number i saw
was over 700 percent as far as you know
refugees coming
to the border uh we have drugs coming
over we have crime
and uh as a people we're trying to take
care of our own right now the people who
have come in here legally and
it's not enough we're like like you just
mentioned earlier you know about
stimulus and giving money
uh you know the implications of people
going out on the streets so
i believe we need to protect our border
have a process adhere to that
and then we can start being stronger as
a country and then we can help and give
aid to people that are in trouble
what's your stance on daca daca i'm
sorry i'm not familiar with daca what's
the most important issue for you
um our freedom i would say that our
freedom is the biggest thing and
when i you know kind of uh was grappling
about
running for u.s senate i was like what
am i going to do differently than anyone
else
um i see just so many things flying on
social media and i want to build yet
another metaphoric
wall around our rights and our
privileges
uh for instance i believe the government
is two protectants to serve just like
you know our police and before
phones were only in our tel you know in
our homes they weren't in cars
and so later when they were causing
accidents that's when
they needed to step in and put a law in
place to protect us from you know not
driving recklessly
i think it's you know the the same thing
now we need to build metaphoric walls
around things we didn't know we needed
to protect
for instance i love the role of a mom
a she a woman i don't want those rights
taken away
in our school system education in
government
i don't mind anybody coming up with
whatever you'd like to be called
in addition but i want to make sure my
rights to be
called a she a her a woman are protected
uh the right to to assemble
churches you know coming together i'm i
love going to church
and i think that people need hope in a
time like this
how do you feel about the current uh
miss nevada winner being transgender
um so for me uh something that's really
important is that we adhere by role so
throughout all of history
you know the pageant has had in their
roles you need to be a natural-born
woman
so i i don't know that that was changed
beforehand so i really think that that
should be something that's looked at
you know because that means that the
person who did win
obviously they thought that person was
the right person but we need to go back
to the rules
that were set specifically to run in
this pageant that you be a natural-born
woman
anything else you feel like people
should know about you personally
personally um i think that
something that's important is to not
judge a book by its cover you know i
i up until this point so many people are
kind of desperating
and kind of seeing from the outside
instead of taking the time to get to
know me
i'm multi-layered i also know how to
kick off the heels
throw on some boots and get some stuff
done so whether it's building i'm going
to be in there
demolishing or or putting you know walls
up i'll do whatever it takes
um so i think that's the biggest thing
to understand for people who will watch
this interview
um they may be surprised that you
weren't familiar with daca it's
something that affects
many people here um what do you want to
address about that do you think you
maybe have more work to do
to be taken seriously and and jump into
the race
um so i look at it as this you know when
i went to this i knew that i wasn't
going to know everything
about every single uh you know question
that i'm asked
and i see it as i have people around me
for the right reason i'm going to
appoint them they're going to advise me
and when it comes time for me to make a
decision on that
i am going to personally do that deep
dive to make sure i'm making the right
decision for the people
taking me seriously i believe that you
know my past shows
that i'm a get it done kind of person so
when that scenario arises
i will address it and do the right thing
for the people
we have that full interview with her on
eight newsnow.com look for the politics
tab
we asked her about her support for
president trump and her stance on
federal lands
and we'll keep putting interviews up
there as we get her opponents
as well the nevada press association and
the state
aclu are suing to ensure reporters can
cover
an upcoming execution convicted murderer
zane floyd is scheduled to be put to
death later this year
with a never-before-used drug cocktail
i talked with aclu of nevada attorney
chris peterson about the lawsuit
so tell me what the goal of the lawsuit
is
well the goal is transparency um we have
a historic execution
that the state is trying to move forward
with it's historic in the sense that
the state of nevada hasn't executed
anyone in the last 15 years
it's historic in the sense that the last
legislative session
saw a bill get through the house that
was trying to abolish the death penalty
and it's also historic in that they're
experimenting with a new drug cocktail
and throughout the history of this
country and other jurisdictions
when there have been experimentation
with drug cocktail
there's been some pretty disturbing
results so
we're representing the press and the
press access to the execution itself
because the press acts as a proxy for
the public they observe what's going
on and they report out what's happened
during execution
and in executions where there's a decent
chance that something will go wrong
and in executions in the past where
something has gone wrong the
media and the press have played a really
important role to let the public
know hey this didn't go as planned i
think it's interesting because in nevada
we often
hear leaders when questioned about
transparency
say that they are all for transparency
but when it comes down to it for
reporters on the ground
we are often denied basic information do
you think this is just
another example so i don't necessarily
want to talk
about other things outside the context
we're working with here but i do
think that when you look at government
and this is something going
to what's going on right here is that
it's understandable that any government
agency is going to be worried about how
they'll look
when they're doing something so
sensitive like executing somebody
when you're killing someone in the name
of the public you don't want
there to get out that you didn't do this
properly or didn't look right
and but the reality though is that the
government
doesn't have a right to simply hide away
where it fails right and it can't just
block the public from seeing what's
happening and it's particularly
important in situations where
the state is using its power and the
most pure and
serious way possible in killing one of
our citizens
so it's understandable
why the government would not want to be
transparent and why they would pay lip
service to that
but in fact not want to be transparent
but the reality is the constitution
requires them to be transparent
we'll stay on top of this case and bring
you any updates i've also
put in a request to cover the execution
running on immigration everybody knows
that
if you have an open border then you
really aren't protecting the citizens of
this country
up next we talk with republican
congressional district 4 candidate and
trump supporter carolina serrano
plus rebuilding the country is it
possible congress finally has an
infrastructure deal
we'll tell you what's in the work
welcome back to politics now
incumbent congressman stephen horsford
has drawn a few republicans planning to
run against him
one is carolina serrano who's a
colombian-american born in the u.s
she worked on the trump campaign in
nevada and she's a unlv graduate
turns out she was also once an intern
here at channel 8.
john langler talked with her about her
campaign
you've been supported notably you've
gotten some donations already from steve
wynn
how did that happen and obviously given
mr winn's recent
history did you have any hesitation
about taking his donations
i didn't because i worked for one in
encore for almost eight years
and i would say in my 13 years in the
service industry those eight years were
the best ones
and so having his support means a lot i
have a lot of respect for
what his vision and how he's changed las
vegas so i'm happy to have it
you just discussed about your connection
with folks who work in the service
industry in las vegas
we've been through such a difficult time
with the pandemic and the resorts were
shut down for such a long time what do
they need in your opinion what do they
need to get back on their feet to find
employment or if they're already
employed
how to get back on even terms i think
that they
need other options besides the service
industry like i said i mean
it's great for a bit of time but it
doesn't have that longevity that you
need in order for you to be able to
build a home have a family have you know
create wealth i would say so i think
that there's just other
options outside the earth service
industry would be good for them so so
from a policy standpoint then what does
that
what does that look like in terms of
getting them out of the cycle of the
service industry
so i would say you know hospitality is
great if if you want to stay in it but i
would say
i would love to see policies that bring
back manufacturing to
the us right because we don't really
produce much here in the us
and i think you know one of the
industries that i would love to see come
down here would be the fashion industry
i think it would be
such a great place to have that industry
here in vegas where
vegas is kind of this fancy glitzy place
you know your announcement you spoke a
lot about immigration
and build finishing the wall why is that
such an important issue
why do you think the wall needs to be in
your words finished well i think it's
always been a an important issue i mean
i voted democrat and
before they were always about protecting
the border and protecting the country i
think
everybody knows that if you have an open
border then you really aren't protecting
the citizens of this country right it
just becomes
chaotic so the border wall is important
and then there also needs to be a total
immigration overhaul because also the
people who are coming here to
have a better life for themselves
they're not benefiting from an open
border either because each time
a new crop comes in that's lower wages
for
for big business and not beneficial to
the people who are trying to make it
when you say open border the border
isn't necessarily open obviously there
are
there it's not is open a fair way to
describe our borders right now
yeah because i mean if you go down to
like texas i love road tripping so i've
been down to texas arizona
it's vast lands and you see people
crossing through
where there isn't a border there's no
barrier right
and so yeah i mean dhs we know is
overwhelmed
and so i would say that they're
releasing a lot of people into the
country
and they have no date to show up most
people don't show up to the dates
so it's a problem you help support
former president trump in his
re-election campaign
uh how much of that experience would you
bring into
a primary and a general election
campaign how much do you lean
on the former president do you still
support him do you think he should still
be president
well obviously i worked on his campaign
it was a great experience so yes i
support the president
um i think that that experience was one
of the best experiences and i would say
that everyone should
knock doors in their community because
you find out that you have a lot more in
common
with your neighbor than you think and so
i think there's a lot more in common
between
people who are trump supporters and
people who are bernie supporters and you
could
bring them together on certain issues
we have that full interview up at
8newsnow.com so far she's raised about
50
000 for her campaign her other
republican opponent so far
is sam peters putting out the flames
we need more body as bodies and we need
more air support
up next the changes steve sisilak and
other western governors want to see made
to how we tackle wildfires in the west
plus do we finally have a deal our
washington d.c bureau breaks down what's
in a deal on our country's important
infrastructure the governors of nevada
and california
are asking the federal government for
more help and
money to fight wildfires they made the
comments while touring the damage from
the tamarack fire in gardnerville nevada
that fire started on federal land in
california
then spread to nevada it has forced 16
000 people out of their homes both
governors say they are having a
conversation with president biden
later this week this may sound like deja
vu but
congress is one step closer to closing a
deal on the president's massive
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure plan
a procedural vote passed with 67 yeses
in the normally split senate as it
stands the bill contains
550 billion dollars in new spending
for public works projects members of
both parties say they believe a final
deal
will happen at a time when washington
seems broken
this group of members behind me came
together each of us are deeply committed
to demonstrating to the country and to
the world
that our government can work and it can
work for the people of the united states
of america
john langler talked with our washington
d.c bureau correspondent alexandra
lamone about the next steps for the bill
and what to expect before this it had
only been a small group of bipartisan
senators that had been working on the
deal behind the scenes so
this makes the process more official and
more likely to head on the road to
actually being passed but it doesn't
guarantee that
the full senate still has to come to an
agreement on this one trillion dollar
proposal
and then the measure would need to get
60 votes in order to pass in the u.s
senate
well alex the president biden top
democrats they had much more ambitious
plans 3.5 trillion dollar package they
talked about with
human infrastructure where do things
stand on that
aspect of the discussion right that was
a really
sweeping proposal that the president and
top democrats want to pass that includes
investments in things like
clean and green energy across the
country
and also in those human infrastructure
measures that you mentioned like
free pre-k education and community
college
for all students the democrats were
hoping to pass that
separately with a process called budget
reconciliation
that would only require 50 votes in
order for that to pass
in the senate rather than 60 well it
looks like that is in jeopardy now too
because democratic senator kirsten
cinema of arizona said
she does not support the idea of
spending 3.5
trillion dollars i mean that is just a
massive number so she says she is not on
board
and democrats need every single democrat
on board so
they are now forced to work with her to
either try to scale back or rework the
package into something that she might
support
if they want any hope of passing that at
all
we'll see where things go on capitol
hill alex limon thank you for joining us
you appreciate it
you're watching politics now
so earlier this week i did a story about
a man who's now living in las vegas but
working in southern california
it's about a four-hour drive he's been
doing for more than a year
the dmv told us that in the first six
months of 2021 more than
22 000 californians turned in their
licenses and ids in nevada
you can check out that story at our
website eightnewsnow.com it's gotten a
lot of comments from people
not too happy about the californians
moving to nevada tell us what you think
thanks so much for joining us at
politics now